and biden directed the department of
education to pause federal student loan
repayments through september of that
year he has since extended it twice uh
today being the third extension millions
of amendments were strong of course at
that time
because of the pause and repayments 41
million americans were able to breathe a
little easier during some of the tough
days of the coven 19 pandemic today is
america is stronger than we were a year
ago and we will be younger a year from
now than we are today however as our
administration recognized and
re-extended the covenanting national
emergency we are still recovering from
the pandemic and the unprecedented
economic disruption it caused which is
of course is the root reason for this
extension in order to enable americans
to continue to get back on their feet
after two of the hardest years this
nation has ever faced we have announced
earlier today of course the plan to the
extension of the paws on federal student
loan repayments through august 31st
of this year that additional time will
assist borrowers in achieving greater
financial security and support the
department of education's efforts to
continue improving student loan programs
also would note
one note on the covet funding bill
we have made clear for months about our
funding needs
and at every step of the way we provided
the details that republicans have asked
for even when they've asked for uh has
changed in real time i have a little
prop here i'm just going to call him
vanna over here thank you
this is kevin munoz um
this is 385 pages of information we have
given to capitol hill and briefed them
on how coveted funding has been spent uh
what we need what the needs are these
are the kind of details we have provided
and constantly briefed members on the
hill to make clear to them what the
impact will be if we do not get this
funding you can have access to this for
a prop if you would like it as well
we'll make copies for you thank you
thank you okay
um
but unfortunately um
as we've gone through before
going back to january while we've worked
going back to january with members of
congress democrats and republicans on
the funding needs we've hosted dozens of
briefings we've held more than three
dozen conference calls we've shared more
than a dozen funding tables all
available 385 pages and we've also given
congress a full accounting of every
dollar that's been spent on the coven
medical response and a full accounting
of the entire american rescue plan which
as you all know goes well beyond the
direct medical needs we've also provided
all the specifics of planned additional
funding how will be deployed against the
additional purchase of monoclonals and
pills and vaccine
vaccines and unfortunately even after
senate leadership agreed upon a
on a paired down bipartisan bill senate
republicans decided to move the goal
post yet again and force amendment votes
on something completely independent of
our covid response needs and at this
point we the question we have is whether
republicans are acting in good faith to
provide the resources we need to save
american lives or if they are just
playing politics the virus is not
waiting for republicans in congress to
get their act together we know ba ii is
here we know that it is more
transmissible we know that it is leading
to increased cases and we know we're
already seeing an impact on our
resources the program that reimbursed
doctors pharmacists and other providers
for vaccinating the uninsured had to end
yesterday due to a lack of funds
america's supply of monoclonal
antibodies that are effective at keeping
people out of the hospital will run out
as soon as late may and our test
manufacturing capacity will begin
ramping down at the end of june so we're
going to continue to work closely with
congress to drive to a solution because
the president knows that we can't afford
an action in this moment it's going to
require politicians stopping to stop
skirting their responsibility to the
american people covet is not over
and we have an obligation to protect our
country the american people and make
sure we're taking steps to prepare
finally last thing
last night as you may have all seen
uh we announced uh the authorization of
an additional 100 million dollars in
security systems the department of
defense announced uh to ukraine through
president through presidential drawdown
authority this package will meet
ukraine's urgent need for additional
javelin anti-armor systems which we have
been providing to ukraine and they have
been using effectively to defend their
country the javelins have been one of
the most effective weapons
the ukrainians have been have deployed
in combating russian tanks and russian
armored vehicles they were critical in
the defense of kiev and other areas and
we want to ensure we continue to get
them in the ukrainians hands we also
continue to work with our allies and
partners to provide ukraine with
additional capabilities and expect to
have more to announce in the coming days
kevin's been out here before so i have
already embarrassed him in the past and
i will keep it short but kevin as many
of you know is our coveted spokesperson
kevin only recently turned 26 which
means he can barely rent a car but he is
he can now uh but he he has become an
expert he is stalwart he works 20 hours
a day um and he is indispensable and so
i'm very grateful to kevin and happy
he's out here to provide the prop but
also to provide all of you with many
many answers on a daily basis okay with
that zeke thanks um you just mentioned
that hey kobet isn't over we just want
the president to give his remarks to him
very large crowd and indoors i was
hoping to speak a little bit to how the
president's views
sort of what when what went into safer
going to
such large galleries is that that sort
of thing he's trying to model for the
rest of the american public that the
risks for most people from copen now or
lesser than they were a year or two ago
before vaccines and their treatments
that sort of behavior now it's not
something that should be stigmatized or
and should be embraced sure i think what
the president is doing is he is
following cdc protocols and models
and that's exactly what we would
recommend
the rest of the country do
that includes getting vaccinated getting
boosted getting an extra booster if you
were eligible as the president did just
last week
and obviously taking any steps or
precautions uh that the cdc recommends
to keep yourself safe and obviously in
washington dc uh we remain in a yellow
zone and the president follows those
protocols as needed
last time the president tested for
coverage i suspected you would ask this
i've asked this question and i will get
you an answer to that as quickly as
possible um as you know he has tested
his regular testing cadence um is
usually tested a couple times a week and
we will venture to get you that as soon
as possible after the briefing that's a
different topic the us today
sanctioned
a number of russians including vladimir
putin's daughters as well some other
individuals
speaking about that sort of the
administration's thinking about
when are family members of
oligarchs and russian government
officials sort of fair game for
sanctions and
how you weigh the destructive decisions
between minors and adults in this case
sort of you know collective punishment
or trying to prevent them from covering
assets with you know people who are not
necessarily involved in the decision
making in ukraine
benefit from them well we've seen a
pattern over time of
president putin and russian oligarchs
stash assets and resources in the bank
accounts and
of their family members uh and so this
was an effort to get at those assets um
and that's why these individuals were
sanctioned
but
why the station then between minors and
adults
well again we look at uh where assets
may be stored and stashed and make a
decision and an assessment on what's
appropriate
go ahead
um the new york times has a verified
video that appears to show a group of
ukrainian soldiers killing captured
russian troops outside a village just
west of keith has the white house seen
these videos do you have a response is
it something you're investigating
i have seen the video i don't have any
confirmation or validation of the video
or the report
and uh
so far the administration or the what
the us has spent about two billion
dollars since the beginning of this
invasion obviously you know you've said
the us is committed to doing everything
it can to help ukraine in this fight but
but if general milly is correct in what
he said yesterday this really could go
on for several years
are these numbers sustainable over the
long term can you keep up at this pace
well i would say first just to reiterate
what general milley said and the
president has also been clear that there
are tough days ahead for the ukrainian
people there's a likely scenario where
there this could go on for some time and
even as they have moved their forces and
they've retreated from kiev they were
treated from the north and the west and
they're consolidating forces in the east
and in the donbas and we've warned that
we're entering a new phase of the
conflict that could last for some time
it doesn't mean it will look exactly the
same or the needs or the resources will
be exactly the same and that is
something we will continue to assess in
our conversations with the ukrainians as
well as with our allies and partners
around the world um and right now uh
just to note obviously our focus is on
uh amping up and providing a range of
military assistance the 100 million
dollars for javelins is a good example
of that as they earn an active uh fight
every single day against the russian
military also humanitarian and economic
assistance and there will be different
needs that will come about over the
course of time and that's something we
are of course committed to continuing to
support uh their recovery from this
their continued fight uh from this uh
but i can't make an assessment about
sustaining because obviously this war
and the needs will change over the
course of time and if this is a really
protracted prolonged conflict uh given
what the treasury secretary said today
sort of warning of the enormous economic
repercussions
of this war for the whole world
what does this mean for the economy in
the us for the next year or two can you
just give us sort of a big picture of
what americans should be bracing for
well as we've made decisions about
putting sanctions in place we've
continued to do that through the prism
of maximizing the impact on russia and
the russian economy while minimizing the
impact on
the west and the united states
obviously there are areas where there
has been an impact including on the
price of gas and you saw the federal
reserve convey today the impact of the
russian invasion on inflation and we
know that to be the case um but what
we're trying to do is mitigate those
impacts and obviously not just the
announcement of the strategic release
from the strategic petroleum reserve but
the announcement by the iae iea today
is the largest release that they have
ever done in history and all of these
are part of our collective effort to
impact to mitigate the impacts on the
american people over the course of time
even the length of time of the release
from the strategic petroleum reserve
meant to be a stop gap measure kind of a
bridge measure to get to the point where
oil companies could produce more is
intended to have a mitigation impact
over the course of time so like what
we're doing is anticipating and trying
to step take steps to reduce the impact
on the american people over time
following up on that iea question do you
have a
a detail or figure of how much oil has
been released to 180 million barrels
today i'm happy to get that for you i'm
sure that our team may have that but i
don't have that in front of me can i ask
a president today told union members
amazon here we come was he endorsing the
efforts of union of workers to unionize
amazon facilities what what he was not
doing is sending a message that he or
the u.s government would be directly
involved in any of these efforts or take
any direct action uh what he was
conveying uh is that uh is his longtime
support for collective bargaining for
the rights of worker networkers to
organize and their decision to do
exactly that in this case uh something
that he has long supported broadly over
the course of his career
go ahead just back to the issue of the
sanctions that are being imposed on
putin's children obviously sanctions
against him as well does the u.s have a
rough estimate at this moment in time of
how much of his assets are tied up
versus what he still might have access
to i don't have an assessment to offer
from here on that
but we know that we've seen attempts and
efforts to stash assets uh in the
accounts and resources of his children
a senior administration official earlier
today was raising the question of
putin's end game um that at some point
he would presumably recognize that this
war has been a failure for him
given some of the scenes that we're
seeing in places like bucha and mario
paul does the us believe that he is any
closer to realizing that reality today
versus a week ago a month ago so
remember the scenes we're seeing in
bucha are from events and atrocities
that didn't happen yesterday they
happened some time ago right and there
will be more of those which our
secretary of state and our national
security advisor have also predicted
unfortunately because there are a lot of
areas of the country where russia has
invaded and committed atrocities no
doubt which we have not yet had visual
access to
um i would say that
i can't make an assessment for you from
here on what is in president putin's
mind what we do know is that because of
the
impact of the economic sanctions
including the ones we have taken today
and steps we've taken over the course of
time we have seen an unquestionable
significant impact on russia's economy
and that has led to
this question now as a result of the
decision around whether or not they
would be able to make a bond payment
earlier this week that they will have to
decide whether they are going to spend
down uh dollars and resources they have
uh to to avoid default or whether
they're going to spend that much
continue to spend that money in funding
the war and that is a part of our
objective is to force them into a place
where they are making that decision but
we've seen
russian's economy collapse by 15 percent
wiping out the gains it made in the last
15 years inflation is spiking up to 15
percent russia is set to lose its status
as a major economy and our objective is
to implement those consequences to make
it much more difficult for president
putin to fund the war and we're seeing
the direct impacts of that already and
to make it clear that this was a
strategic blunder and we're already
seeing those impacts on the economy how
that impacts him and you know that that
is not something i can predict in terms
of getting into his mind
what is the administration's current
assessment of what putin's endgame is
and does the administration believe that
that may have shifted since the
beginning of the invasion
well we um i would say that one while
they have moved to their troops around
and repositioned
we have not uh made and they haven't
made many airstrikes in the last 24
hours according to the department of
defense and their briefing which you may
have seen or their backgrounder
we also know uh that uh you know their
goal remains uh weakening ukraine as
much as possible um and we should be
under no illusion that that objective uh
hasn't changed even as their uh tactics
have
changed um the president today as he was
talking about his vow to stand by
ukrainians added a line and by the way
if i've got to go to war
i'm going with you guys
can you clarify what that meant there's
no intention of sending troops to the
ground or fighting a war uh between uh
with the u.s forces against russia that
was a reflection of his
long love for labor unions and members
of labor unions and the building and
trades workers who were there and people
that he would always love to be in the
foxhole with not an indication of a
change in u.s policy he also
referred to that heated exchange we saw
that involved secretary austin and he
said with regard to ukrainian troops
we've trained them and we've given them
the weapons um can you clarify what he
meant by we have trained them what
training was he talking about there was
some some time ago training and we have
provided them obviously a range of
weapons over time what point he was
making is one secretary austin made
yesterday without the extensive military
assistance that we have been providing
the ukrainians the security assistance
over the course of the last uh several
weeks and and even months before that
1.6 billion dollars worth maybe a little
higher now after 100 million last night
they would not have been able to
effectively fight back as they have and
how it has basically worked is they have
requested a range of assistance we go
through and see what we are able to
provide we often work with partners and
allies to provide assistance we don't
have access here and then we expedite
the delivery of that over the course of
time whether that is javelin stingers or
a range of materials that are the us
military has determined they're not only
trained on but has been effective in
fighting this war but aside from the
physical resources what training was he
talking about what was the latest
training the u.s troops have done
there's not new training to report out
to you what he was really emphasizing
and the important part here is what
secretary austin was also talking about
is the military equipment that has been
provided that has allowed them to fight
this war
on sanctions you've said a couple times
now that um you know the u.s sanctioned
kun's daughters because there's reason
to believe putin has stashed his wealth
with them does that mean that the u.s
has some information about where the
billionaire daughters are stashing their
wealth i don't have any more to provide
to you uh from here uh we make
assessments about where to implement
financial sanctions to uh get close to
not only the assets of president putin
but those around him and we have seen a
long pattern of using relatives and
family members to stash wealth
thank you jen first on immigration our
team in texas is
saying that you guys are starting to
give smart phones to border crossers
hoping that they'll use the phones to
check in or
to be tracked i which part of that is
supposed to deter people from crossing
illegally into the states well i think
you of all people since you've asked me
a range of questions on this topic over
time would recognize that we need to
take steps to ensure that we know where
individuals are and we can track and we
can check in with them the alternatives
to detention program is just what we
utilize as three unique forms of
technology to monitor participants
enrolled in the program telephonic which
is one of them which is uses a
participant's voice to create a
biometric voice print during the
enrollment process and when the
participant has a check-in call their
voice is compared to the voice print
smart link which is another option
enables participant monitoring via
smartphone or tablet using facial
matching technology to establish
identity and global positioning system
monitoring is of a participant's
location and movement history using
satellite technology through an ankle
bracelet this is all part of our effort
as individuals come into
the united states and individuals who
are entering who will proceed to
immigration proceedings to monitor and
track where they are with the telephonic
though any concern by folks around here
that these migrants will take the phones
and just toss them
do you have a record of people throwing
phones away
if that's a concern
our concern is ensuring that individuals
who
irregularly migrate to the united states
proceed through uh our process of uh you
know of course being monitored but also
participating in uh in uh pr
in hearings uh to determine whether or
not they will be able to stay i would
note that nearly eighty percent of
non-citizens released at the border from
dhs custody under prosecute
prosecutorial discretion have either
received a notice to appear or are still
within their window to report so
actually the vast vast majority of
people are appearing in part we have
these monitors and monitoring systems
and in order to do that effectively on
another topic was it common for
president biden to do favors for hunter
biden's international business partners
like writing college recommendations for
their kids
i have i've seen the report i have no
confirmation or comment on a report
about whether or not the president when
he was a private citizen wrote a college
recommendation letter for an individual
i a college recommendation letter though
from
at the time a former vice president
would be a big deal so do we know what
president might have gotten in return
for doing a favor like that again i have
no a confirmation of any recommendation
letter the president wrote when he was a
private citizen by the way not uh
serving in public office that's even the
report but he's the president now and
you're his spokesperson
correct and
he was not the president at the time of
this report
so there's evidence that the president
at one point was office mates with
hunter and his brother jim here in d.c
it's not accurate that is not accurate
so when hunter biden is emailing a
landlord uh please have keys made
available for new office mates joe biden
jill biden jim biden that you're
disputing we're not office mates no they
were not office mates okay great go
ahead well thanks jen um on student
loans briefly you were sort of asked
about this yesterday but i just wanted
to come back to it so as people plan for
the future
um should borrowers expect that after
august 31st they'll have to repay their
loans or is there another is there a
chance that it could be further extended
after august 31st we'll continue to
assess and what we look at well of
course the economy is in a better state
than it is than it was a year ago um and
it's we have a strong recovery we also
understand that there are a range of
impacts that are still longer lasting
because of the pandemic
including the impacts on costs and
inflation and this is part of the
president's effort to help alleviate
that as was fixed as that was the family
glitch announcement of yesterday so
we'll uh make an evaluation department
of education we'll look at that on a
range of factors as we get closer to
that timeline has the president
at this point ruled out the possible
executive level cancellation on a wide
scale of student debt uh he has not
ruled out um but i don't have any update
on that and i would note that again he
would encourage congress to send him a
bill uh cancelling ten thousand dollars
in student debt something that he talked
about uh
looking forward to signing on that on
the campaign just really briefly on the
220 yeah the secretary yellen said today
that they may not that that the u.s
might attend meetings if russians are
there
is that is she implying that these would
just be individual meetings or would it
would it be a kind of broader scale
boycott of the g20 involved
she i think they have later clarified
she was referencing at the ministerial
level and more specific meetings i would
point you to them of the more specifics
the president has also said he said on
the trip that he did not think russia
should be a part of the g20 you know
meeting um and i would note it's seven
months away which is a lifetime in our
uh in our lives but it wasn't an
indication of plans for us to boycott or
not attend it was just it shouldn't be
business as usual which is something the
president has also said
is it a priority of the president to try
to identify the russian units that
carried out the atrocities in busha is
that something the u.s may be able to do
and is it something the president wants
to have
we will continue to assist in every way
possible uh with these efforts to track
down data additional information and
contribute to the international effort
to do exactly that let me ask if i can a
couple other questions that make news
today a judge has just issued the first
outright acquittal of the defendant
charge and the january 6th capital riot
this was a new mexico man matthew martin
he was acquitted on some misdemeanor
charges by the judge this man had
claimed that he thought police allowed
him into an entrance near the capital
rotunda does the white house have any
view now that that
i don't case has been
comment on that case uh we continue to
support the efforts of the january 6
commission uh and all of the members in
trying to get the bottom of what
happened that day to prevent it from
happening in the future let me go back
to one last question as it relates to
what's happening in russia the u.s still
doesn't have an ambassador to india it
appears increasingly clear that los
angeles
mayor garcetti doesn't have the votes
right now to be confirmed how does the
lack of an ambassador to india impact
our ability america's ability to
pressure india not to work
with russia in providing any aid
resistance well our preference is always
to have a confirmed ambassador on the
ground it's an incredibly important
diplomatic position we also engage with
countries through a range of channels
and obviously our deputy national
security advisor was just in india
recently in the last few weeks uh
conveying clearly what the consequences
of violating sanctions would be and what
the mechanisms are and also making clear
that uh that we do not think india
should accelerate or increase imports of
russian energy and other commodities
even as obviously those decisions are
made by individual countries and also
making clear that we stand ready to
support india as in any efforts to
diversify its imports and serve as a
reliable supplier even as they're only
importing about one to two percent of
their oil from from india so we have a
range of ways to communicate and engage
and obviously sending our deputy
national security advisor is an example
of that but clearly our preference would
be to have a confirmed bathroom still
support that nomination but he does
the russian rule has been on the rise uh
victor urban in hungary said today that
he'd be happy to pay for russian gas in
rubles that he's happy to buy more
russian tax
is there anything the u.s can do about
this are you engaging
hungary on this point
uh well i would i would first say in
terms of the ruble the reason uh it's
important to note that the russian
central bank is making extreme policy
decisions to artificially prop up the
ruble so it's not actually
on the rise it is being artificially
propped up by limitations that they are
putting in place including barring banks
from selling dollars to customers
russian brokerages or not allowing
foreign clients to sell securities
exporters are being forced to sell
eighty percent of their dollar revenues
and buy rubles so they are essentially
manipulating it on their end um as it
relates to hungary uh i mean slightly a
different question but um
our um
you know obviously there was the recent
election as you noted um of uh of victor
orban um i would note that um our hungry
is a nato ally continues to be we
continue to cooperate on a range of
bilateral and shared global interests
including on nato defense and on
humanitarian assistance
they're currently hosting forces from an
army striker infantry troop as part of a
nato battle group we regularly conduct
joint training exercises
with them and we will continue to work
to strengthen our partnership with
hungary uh obviously uh reliance on the
ruble is a decision individual countries
will make and we've obviously made our
views clear on that front
you have engaged hungary on this
question that's not what i conveyed i
just conveyed their nato ally go ahead
go back to the sanctions as they were
announced this morning the spare bank
and the alpha bank connections i believe
exclude
energy they're full blocking technology
excluding energy similarly the soe
sanctions coming tomorrow also will not
affect the energy sector can you speak
to that balancing act is that because
you're worried about domestic impact
here in the us on the price of natural
gas price gasoline or that because the
europeans
asked you to sort of carve that out why
or why why is that still sort of a
bridge too far for the us on these
sanctions they're not really blocking
sanctions if they're splitting it well i
mean i would say they're they're quite
extensive given spare bank is uh the
largest bank uh in russia and alpha bank
is the largest private bank in russia so
uh and in total we're now fully back
more than two-thirds of russia's banking
sector uh these conversations and
discussions obviously are done in
coordination with our european allies
and partners and we continue to assess
how we can maximize the impact while
minimizing the impact on other economies
including of course uh the global global
oil marketplace and we've taken steps of
course banning oil imports a number of
countries including poland in europe
have announced their intention to take
uh steps but that's up to individual
countries to make but it's part
coordination assessment um with uh with
other countries and our allies about the
impacts but i would still say it's a
quite a significant step given they're
the largest bank in russia
this was done because of the europeans
saying hey you know this would be no
this is but we do update them and brief
them on the steps we take and why and we
look at the impacts on on how things
will impact the united states how they
will impact a range of our allies as we
make decisions about sanctions very
quickly and the central bank is propping
up the rubles do you have any sense of
how long they're able to keep that up i
don't have an assessment uh from here at
this point in time on that go ahead
on the immigration
with the lifting of section 42 there are
a lot of democrats particularly
democratic senators up for re-election
who worried that you don't have a plan
to either stop the spring surge of
undocumented immigrants or handle it
could you
what do you say to those democrats well
i would first say that title 42 is not
an immigration measure it's a public
health measure and one that congress has
given the cdc authority to make a
decision about and we respect that and
think that's that's absolutely right um
this is why the president proposed an
immigration bill on his first day in
office and we would certainly welcome
efforts of anybody to work with us on
that but as we're implementing this over
the course of the next five weeks i'm
doing my math correctly we've also
surged resources from the department of
homeland security and we will continue
to take additional steps to implement um
and make clear
that this is not the time to come
that there are um there will still be
significant measures put in place for
anyone who tries to
regularly migrate to the united states
do you feel that you i mean what's your
goal and what do you expect what what
impact do you expect to have on the
spring surge with those kinds of
measures
i would really point you to the
department of homeland security to make
any projections of that because we have
not made any projections of what it will
mean in terms of the
the
the ending of title 42 either
thanks i know that you've talked about
the stringent measures you've taken to
keep the presidency from covet that go
beyond the cdc guidelines but that's
such a visual contrast between that and
the president showing up massless in
front of them and people at some of
these events
so how do you make sure that you keep
that protection bubble around him i'm
sure you feel like you're asked to
explain this agnosium but the bubbles
looking pretty porous lately
sort of enforced i would say first that
we continue to take measures that go
beyond what the cdc protocols are that
includes ensuring that everybody who's
going to see
the president in a meeting is tested in
advance
or if you're traveling with the
president you're tested in advance uh
when possible we take steps to socially
distance in circumstances which
certainly the oval office and other
meeting spaces in the white house allow
for if an individual in the white house
is a close contact they are asked to or
required to i guess you could say wear a
mask for
10 days after that exposure and they are
also tested regularly following so i
would say we take additional measures
that go beyond what the cdc protocols
and requirements are
to ensure that we are doing everything
we can to keep uh principal safe the
president the vice president uh and
others of course in the building tested
before the eastern movement tomorrow
everyone who was there
it's not at public events i'm talking
about at meetings but again i can check
on the protocols for public events sure
have you changed any protocols
surrounding him in recent days as more
people are in the administration
contracts this
virus we've continued to implement
stringent and strict protocols i would
note that even as we're looking at with
ba2 a very transmissible variant as we
all know and our public health officials
have told us we've seen an increase in
cases right in the country in the region
among the press corps and certainly in
the white house um and uh but it is not
at this point what we saw
during omicron um and what the steps we
have taken here including a policy put
in place to ensure that return to work
was part of our policies in the federal
government are meant to ensure that can
continue to be the case and even while
we have individuals who are out
with
with covid everyone here is required to
be tested highly recommended to be
boosted uh people who are out because of
that the vast vast majority have mild
cases and are continuing to work from
home and obviously we are continuing to
implement uh the return to work policy
and feel we have the measures necessary
to do that what's the clearest version
of the message that you're trying to
send to americans about
living with this virus even as infection
rates rise i mean that it's not the end
of the world if you get it if you're
boosted i mean is that the message
you send through the president who's
masterless in front of hundreds of
people that this this isn't the end that
we have to live this way is our our
recommend all right well
the message we're sending is to follow
the cdc protocols and guidance for where
you live the president does that he did
an event in washington dc today uh where
it does not require mask wearing uh
there are other parts of the country as
you know where he's traveled and he has
worn a mask where that has been the
recommendation our protocols also here
we and we would certainly project this
to the american people are that getting
getting um
vaccinated and getting boosted and if
you are immunocompromised are you over a
certain age getting your next booster is
certainly a way to help protect yourself
that's something the president has done
and every member of the senior staff and
white house staff has done and will
continue to do although some of us are
teasing the people who are over 50 that
we're not old enough yet but that's a
side that's a sidebar when we are we
will we will be doing that as well um so
it is it is to follow the protocols and
to recognize that the statistics show
you are significantly more likely to be
hospitalized and even to die if you are
not vaccinated if you're not boosted and
yes we are living with covid19 we are
continuing to fight it and our biggest
message right now is that we need the
resources from congress to continue to
have the uh to to ensure we have
programs for the uninsured that we can
provide
uh
treatments for immuno compromise that we
can make sure that we have testing
mechanisms and booster mechanisms and
we're going to we're at serious risk of
of those programs not being able to
continue
the title 42 question you said that the
administration will be taking uh
additional steps to make clear this is
not the time to come that was of course
a pretty explicit message from the
president and others last year do not
come is that still the message on may
24th
yes
that as the u.s moves to end title 42 in
may are there discussions now or is
there any update you can give us on
ending the testing requirement for
re-entry into the u.s for people
traveling here i don't have any update
on that at this point in time that's
something we will continue to evaluate
thank you so much
i have a follow-up on sanctions and
energy sure the european union said
yesterday that they are paying uh russia
every day a little more than one billion
dollars for gas and oil how long can
this go on in the president's view
without undermining the collective
effort to punish russia well i would say
that we continue to believe that it's up
to individual countries to make
assessments about what additional
measures they will be put in place while
we are focused on continuing unity with
our nato allies and partners and our
european partners it does not mean that
is always identical and different
countries have to make their own
assessments what we've also tried to do
is take steps to
to ensure there are other options to
reduce dependence even if it's a small
percentage and if there's a varying as
you well know degree of reliance uh for
these countries you're referencing on
russian oil and some of them have taken
steps to convey they want to reduce or
end their dependence or import of
russian oil and that's something
certainly we'd support and play any
constructive role in helping uh to
helping expedite
in a second
follow up on the question about hungary
are there any plans to engage with them
about this particular topic of paying in
rules at any level in the coming days a
week i'm happy to check with the state
department and see if there's any plans
for engagement about it okay
american catholic thank you
you've talked about the increasing deep
picture of russia's economy uh over the
years public reporting has shown that
white supremacists and other domestic
extremists have developed an affinity
for russia is there any concern that as
the russian economy
continues to degrade that
russia might try and
inspire
domestic extremist domestic terrorists
to commit acts of violence on american
soil in retaliation
it's an interesting and scary question
um i don't have any prediction or
assessment of that nor have i heard a
prediction or assessment of that from
our national security experts or the
department of homeland security i'm
happy to check with them and see if
there's anything on that front
question
okay all right so an american catholic
nun uh has been abducted monday nights
by gunmen and burkina faso in western
africa her name is sister suellen
tennyson she was doing missionary work
there is the white house aware of that
by a chance in her abduction i'm happy
to check with our national security team
and the state department obviously they
would have purview over any
sister tell me your name again
sister tennyson back who clearly was
doing incredible work humanitarian work
it sounds like on behalf of the people
in burkina faso i will check with the
state department and see if there's any
updates on this specific case go ahead
oh okay all right um okay go ahead patsy
go ahead okay thank you i want to follow
up on what you said yesterday about the
lack of global covert funding um and you
explained it essentially means that the
us cannot turn the doses that you
already have into shots and arms and i
believe that the us has already
purchased the 1.2 billion doses that is
pledged
and out of that there is about 680
million that haven't been delivered so
my question then is what will happen to
those doses i know like possibly you
already have funding for
delivery the cold chain storage training
people and so on but what happens to the
rest of it when you are unable to turn
those vaccines into vaccinations well
we're not quite there yet and our hope
is that we will be able to turn them uh
vaccines into vaccinations but as you
know it's not just an issue of vaccine
doses it's the know-how it's the
capacity it's the tools and mechanisms
to be able to
store deliver implement getting shots
into arms in a number of these countries
which why number of countries haven't
even been able to accept the doses that
we've been able to offer because of that
know-how and that is part of the program
that is so essential to fund through
usaid and other
other of our international bodies to do
exactly that but we're not quite at that
point we're going to continue to press
for international funding just like
we're going to continue to press for
domestic funding because we feel it's
important and imperative that we
continue to be uh the arsenal vaccines
around the world
how you want to do that is the goal to
push for a separate package and global
covert funding
i'm not going to get ahead of where we
are obviously uh it was disappointing to
say the least that the package did not
move forward despite an agreement on
that yesterday afternoon but uh what i'm
here to convey is that uh this funding
domestically and internationally is is
imperative uh it's it's urgent uh and
we're going to continue to press for all
of it
one more question on uh visit to india
which was also partly to uh to go on a
listening tour for the build back better
world um that was actually scheduled to
be formally launched early this year so
if you can give us an update on that why
is it not launched yet and at at this
point do you feel that it is with you
know with the projects with the
listening tours uh with the pilot
projects that are being planned is it
robust enough to be introduced to the
world as a viable alternative to china's
belt and rural initiative as you know
the president has used his own time to
talk about build back better world and
how important it is to our efforts to
rebuild infrastructure without the
strings attached around the world um and
um
that that speaks to our commitment to it
and obviously our deputy national
security adviser taking a trip himself
having a discussion about it as a
reflection of our commitment to that in
our efforts
this morning at the monitor breakfast
nec director brian diese mentioned a
classified briefing that took place
earlier today between lawmakers jake
sullivan and others about quote
escalating vulnerabilities around
semiconductors can you tell us more
about this meeting and was it an effort
to get congress to hurry up on the
reconciliation of the two
related bills well i i can't speak to
the specifics of a classified briefing
uh what i can tell you is that uh we can
remain committed to uh supporting
efforts to get euseka passed which
includes significant funding for chips
manufacturing and production
which as we know is a big hindrance to
our ability to manufacture a range of
a range of items in the united states
including cars and others that rely on
chips and this bill has a great deal of
funding for it so i think it was a
reminder and more details that i can't
get into from here on uh on on how
important addressing that shortage and
being able to produce them at home are
moving forward go ahead as the
administration sort of collects this
evidence for a potential war crimes
trial against russian officials does the
u.s does the administration have a
preferred venue for where that type of
trial might take place that there are
obviously a few avenues available to the
international community there are and
there there's a lot of precedent and
that has used different venues so at
this point that determination has not
been made uh what we are doing and i
think i would point to first our
attorney general's comments earlier
today uh about the role of the
department of justice in this effort
moving forward
but we have supported a range of efforts
including
the efforts by the ukrainian special
prosecutor to
gather information
and the work of the war crimes unit
under the ukrainian uh prosecutor
general sorry prosecutor general not
special prosecutor and a team of
international prosecutors who are
working with them we also um in the last
few weeks we helped establish
investigations through the u.n human
rights council and the osce of possible
violations by russia
and we welcome the investigation opened
by the icc prosecutor so there has been
different ways that
war crimes unfortunately there are past
instances and examples have been
have been investigated and tried uh in
the past and and we're going to support
all of these efforts but there hasn't
been a determination yet about what
mechanism it will take
change that all the thinking of the
administration as it relates to the
relationship between the us and the icc
well we are not a member of the icc as
you know uh that hasn't changed we have
supported and contributed data and
information to
icc investigations in the past
there was we supported the u.n security
council's referral of libya to the icc
back in 2011
and if you look back to 2004 we also
provided uh data and information to the
icc investigation of darfur so there is
past precedent even as we have not been
members of the icc go ahead thank you
jen a couple of follow-ups
um
when the president said that the u.s was
training ukrainians was he talking about
training that occurred during his
administration i don't have any other
additional details what he was really
making a point about is what secretary
austin said yesterday which is that
without the extensive and robust
military assistance we have provided uh
the ukrainians would not
have been able to as effectively fight
and push back on the russian invasion
he said amazon here we come
you said that he was generally
expressing his support for
the right to unionize
moments later though news broke that the
sec was beating an investigation of
amazon was that a coincidence no
relation sec is an independent agency
aware that there was an investigation
not that i'm aware of
one final one
this administration has sent everything
from medical supplies to laser
guided rockets to the ukrainians right
now
while this administration is making them
more lethal
is the thought that we are bolstering
their defensive capabilities or is the
administration confident that we are
both sharing their offensive capability
to in fact you know expel russia from
their borders well
their country is being invaded so it's
all defensive they're defending their
sovereign country and the territorial
integrity of ukraine using these weapons
systems that the department of defense
has long categorized as defensive
systems you wouldn't go invade another
country with a lot of these systems the
vast majority of these systems that's
not how you would go about it and
obviously that is not what they're doing
they're trying to protect their own
people their own cities their own
innocent civilians who are being invaded
by a foreign power
okay let me do one more in the back
because i never got to the hound post
and i today is the day
there was a recent report that the
president had expressed some frustration
that the former president had not been
charged without getting to the details
of that there are lots of people being
charged with
obstructing an official proceeding
meaning the january 6th certification
well the former president was doing that
openly his administration was doing why
wouldn't you charge i mean why hasn't
the president
come out and said that if that's the
case
well at first i've never heard the
president say those words or say that
phrase that was reported and i know ron
clint said something similarly so i i
don't know
we
each spend a lot of time with him um but
i would say that um the president from
the beginning
has felt strongly
that the justice department and the
attorney general must operate
independently and any decisions about
prosecution need to be made
independently and that is the strength
of our system even as the former guy
ignored that and
former president nixon ignored it as
well the president does not want to be
in that category of how you approach the
separation of the white house
uh and the department of justice and uh
and he thinks that will even strengthen
our systems uh as they've been weakened
over the last few years okay thanks so
much
all right
all right everybody see you tomorrow
you